une société sans contact n'est pas
viable d'un point de vue delà du plaisir
de la coopération de l'engagement du
faire ensemble de l'éducation
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
ils fabienne martin jeu chaque
professeur en sciences de la
communication a bien cité grenoble alpes
et je suis chercheur en anthropologie de
la communication corporelle et affective
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que la
socialité se joue dans le non verbal
l'essentiel de nos jeux relationnel son
intérieur intériorisé de telle sorte
qu'on ne s'en rend plus du tout content
et c'est vrai que d'imposer et gestes
barrières perturbe les fondements de 70
édifice invisible qui est la société
un mètre de distance qui est imposé et
artificielle et pose de vrais problèmes
relationnels
on a tous l'habitude de s'ajuster
inconsciemment à l'autre en fonction du
type de relation et donc d'adapter la
distance physique en fonction de notre
interlocuteur donc c'est très très très
difficile de s'imposer à rester à un
mètre de quelqu'un
on à se tendre de code pour marquer
notre sympathie notre proximité notre
connaissance à égal à destination
d'autres et c'est ce qu'on appelle les
codes de civilité où les codes de
politesse et ses codes sont présents
dans toutes les sociétés
pour éviter de sang se sentir agressé
est d'adosser autrui en particulier se
serrer la main
c'est vraiment intéressant parce que ça
permet de sentir l'autre par le contact
physique tout en ayant une certaine
distance physique de s'empêcher de faire
ensemble de ces gestes là et bien c'est
le risque de de paraître agressant et
que l'autre soit perçu comme un étranger
et donc c'est particulièrement gênant
puisque déjà il ya virus donc on risque
en fait d'être réellement dans une
situation particulièrement perçu comme
agressante pour les individus
le contact physique est essentielle
le simple fait d'être en contact
physique apaise détention rassure
affectivement et ce contact physique
serait même essentiel pour l'équipe si
chic voire le développement le psychique
de l'individu
[Musique]
dans une situation qu'on ne peut plus
vivre naturellement ce contact physique
peut être pour certains très
déstabilisant soit généré des de
l'anxiété un sentiment d'insécurité de
l' angoisse des perturbations psychiques
victor qui actuellement eu pas mal cité
c'est donc les travaux de bol bien sur
l'attachement 1 minute 20 comme assez
loin avec l'idée que l'élan premier
c'est l'élan de relation avant de
d'avoir besoin de boire ou manger est
quelqu'un qui est privé de relations
sociales il se laisse mourir on l'a vu
par rapport aux et pas de personnes
âgées personnes qui étaient en isolement
pendant cette période de confinement
certains préfèrent en fait on dire voir
revivre cette sociabilité au risque
d'être contaminé
et
de toute manière si les contacts sans
interdit un moment donné les individus
transgresse même des fois inconsciemment
on se retrouve à toucher l'autre parce
qu'on a trop besoin donc à un élan élan
physique vers autrui cette période
particulière en termes de crise
sanitaire
on le voit bien il ya une sorte de de
développement exponentiel du numérique
ainsi au niveau du travail également de
l'éducation et de l'apprentissage
[Musique]
on voit bien aussi récemment dans
certains articles que des individus qui
sont en permanence en télétravail perdre
le sens du plaisir du travail voire même
le plaisir de travailler tout simplement
parce qu'une des éléments un central du
travail c'est de s'éprouver de se
rencontrer
c'est ce contact physique cette
socialité qui se joue en fait dans la
proximité physique
les situations de travail et d'éducation
à distance sont même presque
problématique parce que les gens ne
peuvent pas apprendre à être ensemble
donc là pour le coup on est vraiment en
phase 1 un problème qui pas simplement
une société sans contact mais c'est une
société qui ne donne pas les moyens aux
individus de se sentir appartenir à une
communauté d'avoir du plaisir à faire
ensemble de choses à coopérer qui donne
le sens de la vie
on peut imaginer qu'ils en refermant
quand même des communautés les unes
séparées les unes par rapport aux autres
avec une sorte d' amalgame qui est que
mes amis sont pas contagieux ma
communauté n'est pas contagieuse et les
autres les autres communautés
ce sont les dangereux
[Musique]
et c'est vrai que par rapport à nos
acquis civilisationnels où on a la
possibilité grâce à ce 7e à cette
sécurité sanitaire dans les villes de
créer des espaces communs ou quand les
cultures se rencontrent les hommes et
les femmes s'éprouve où il ya des
variétés de communauté c'est dommage
qu'on perde cette qualité d'échangé
inter culturelle intercommunautaire
puisque les espaces collectifs vont être
aseptisé
c'est vrai que ce serait une sorte de
recul ainsi l'espace public devient un
espace où il se fait rien il se vit rien
et tout se joue dans des micro
communautés qui sont à cacher avec ce
menu une des chaises de socialité donc
c'est vraiment important que assez vite
les institutions publiques les
collectivités trouve les moyens de
recréer des espaces de socialité qui
crée du sens et du faire ensemble malgré
le fait qu'on a le virus
1 ça c'est quand même quelque chose qui
semble essentiel si on veut faire
perdurer notre gré 6 décembre
[Musique]